hi good afternoon i'm delighted to have
many of you here on zoom for our fourth
panel on how to join the quantum
workforce my name is florian carl i'm
the manager of the yale quantum
institute and i'll be the moderator for
that session today
so we are delighted to continue this
series of
professional development panels that are
organized jointly with the engineering
workforce development of the center for
quantum networks in arizona
and yqi so this is the fourth and
penultimate panel in our series and
today we are focusing on how to prepare
for startups so there's many many ways
to enter
the quantum workforce and build quantum
technology and it requires a lot of
different backgrounds we need physicists
we need electrical engineer we need
computer scientists software engineer
chemist and so on and so it can be a bit
overwhelming for people to find the
right career for them and so today we
want to share this information uh with
you all um so we in in this series that
has been recorded that you can go back
and go back and see on our website
we talked about
how to pick your courses for college how
to
join grad school
how to become a faculty member and then
today we're doing startups and in
december we'll do
industry jobs
um so today we'll hear uh by uh
through a young professional what it's
like to work in i'm quantum how to join
uh how to land a job in a startup and
why not create your own
and before i uh introduce our panelists
um i would like to uh give the the space
to matches which is the student
leadership concealed chair of the center
for quantum network and it will say a
word about
cqn
hello everyone thank you for watching
uh well i'm really glad to be this again
president uh representative here today
essentially cqn is a research center
funded by nsf that surprisingly has a
goal to view the quantum network and you
can think that a quantum network is the
generalization of classical internet the
classical internet for quantum computers
and we conduct research in many fields
from the development of quantum hardware
and algorithms to the the investigating
the associated the shadow impact of
quantum technology and uh in addition to
research we also
look at education outreach and workforce
development as pilots of our center and
part of our goal is to also develop
activities to foster academic and
professional development in the student
population and if you would like to
learn more about cqn feel free to reach
out to us
you can look at our website and also
email me thank you
thank you very much and we have some
permission on the slide on my webcam
so now let's start with the uh
the start of the panel let's introduce
our panelists you can turn on your
webcams and then we're gonna start
by
uh
hui
said
about qci
uh if you want to talk a little bit more
about um what you do over there and like
why are you interested in quantum
physics
okay so
i'm ua
z
um i'm a software developer at qci or
just quantum circuits
our office is our new haven science park
and about myself i came from
computer science at the university of
connecticut i have a bachelor's degree
there i went into software consulting
for a bit before i went to develop
a database developer as
for a healthcare company and then
finally qci
so
[Music]
about me i guess i as a software
developer i'm deeply integrated in
contributing mainly to software stack
and
about qci it was founded in 2015 by rob
schokoff michelle devere and luigi
frenzio and their colleagues so they're
the leaders in the quantum computing
field and if you know also professors at
yale
we have a pretty big multi-disciplinary
team of hardware and software engineers
to build the most advanced quantum
machines out there and our goal our
mission is mainly to deliver the world's
first truly useful quantum computer
that's it i guess
feel free to ask me any questions you
have sounds good thank you very much and
it's an interesting uh fun fact is that
your boss is also my boss in a different
educator
but there was uh that was interesting to
uh to see uh let's go to your second
panelist uh maddie do you want to
introduce yourself and i put pull up the
slide about connect
awesome awesome hi everyone i'm mehdi
namazi i'm the co-founder and currently
the chief
science officer at qnx so connect is
very very similar mission as what
matthews was saying
we are trying to develop the hardware
and the software necessary to upgrade
the current telecom infrastructure in
order to make it much more quantum
friendly so not only for applications
like secure inc quantum encryption and
such but also to eventually connect
quantum computers quantum sensors and
pretty much any device that has quantum
nature uh into this network so we just
want to be the building blocks of what
will come much later but more towards
the concept of quantum internet and
network design to
be plot for any and to be used for any
quantum device
i
am from a physics background i did my
phd at the stony brook university i was
a postdoc fellow at
yqi for
what was it more or less 18 or some
months or so yeah
yeah and then around two years ago i i
left and full-time joined at qnec
currently we are at brooklyn navy yard a
team of 10 full-time
scientists and engineers mainly focus on
developing the hardware that can be used
for these applications
thank you very much
uh and then uh let's have a picture
introduce himself and i'll pull up the
slide for
psych city
thank you so much florian so my name is
victor padilla taylor and my pronouns
are he him
i was born in nicaragua
and i actually immigrated to guatemala
because there was a civil war
in my country of origin
[Music]
there i was actually um someone that
loved engineering so got my
bachelor's degree in chemical
engineering and then everything started
just rolling
towards administrative roles in
corporate development uh eventually i
moved uh to the us to get a a master's
degree with the yale's club management
and then moved to non-profits with the
world economic forum and spent four
years until
someone invited me to come here at yale
and
support the creation of this uh new
center for innovation the science center
for innovative thinking at yale so my
role as director of networks is to
create uh you know space for innovators
uh like you all uh to find support for
their their startups nonprofits or even
creative projects so i'm really happy
to be here and hopefully i'll be able to
provide some resources to all of you uh
with us here at side city there's a way
for you to work on your ideas to
fruition
thank you very much oh um so let's start
by uh like a question that i had when i
was running this thing was like the only
thing i've never worked in a startup and
the only thing i have in mind is the
the the very californian vibe of like oh
everybody's working on a scooter they
have fricate area that's my vision of
startups so which i know it's that's
entirely true uh can you can you take a
crack at what it's like to work at a
startup and what what differentiate a
startup to your to a
like a more formal
company and what's your what's your
day-to-day like um
who wants to start
you can just unmute and go
i can go first i can go first uh yeah so
yeah there are plenty of startups like
the silicon valley styles we are a
little bit different
more lane no no scooters for us
but i think the biggest things that
differentiate between between startups
and industry jobs that i'm sure you guys
will cover in a month or so
is the a combination of the
flexibilities you get like we don't have
any time who comes in what time who
lives in what time no one cares about
these things no one cares about how many
days you take off or like what you do
all we care about are the the general
milestones that we have and the things
you want to achieve
and the startup is usually a much more
collaborative space it's
it's not like an industry that the
mission is already well-defined and
usually everything is designed to
optimize the revenue for example
whatever the business is uh in our case
and in most startups it you're you're
still figuring out what the mission is
even gonna be so every player everyone
who joins the company is less of an
employee more often
by all means and purpose is a team mate
because everyone needs to work together
and everyone needs to have several hats
to get to the
to the to the final goal so it's a
little bit less boring when it gets to
the job roles that you have you get to
peak you can switch for a lot of
projects anytime you start a new or if
you have a better idea for how to do the
projects in case like developing the
quantum stuff if you have a better idea
people are there to listen things are
not set a stone uh but but of course it
always comes with this bigger risk that
it is a startup you you always wondering
like what happens in a year in two years
when it gets to like the fundings and
everything like that so it has its own
plus and minuses
sure i guess i'm next
uh so i think a lot of it was covered
already um
to add to that a startup coming from
industry or big corporations there is
more structure
so for example what this means is in a
big corporation when there's a feature
we often go through and have a whole
like session where you discuss this with
like the managers the business side they
will approve this feature and then
finally when it gets to you it's
definitely going to be that it will
change there's no like there's always
a very
clear like map of everything that you
need dog by the end of this week or this
iteration or the sprint
startups is a little bit more free in
the sense that
we try to keep a
we try to keep like a structure as well
for iterations for example but due to
the fact that we work closely with like
the hardware engineers who use our
software we at the same time are also
production support for them because it's
not like we have a separate team for it
and when features come in they sometimes
get prioritized in one way but as we're
going through this might change due to
various reasons
it could be because people want one
thing sooner it could be because we we
just like wanted to switch it because it
wasn't as because some feature wasn't as
important as this other one so
the structure behind startup is a little
more free this is good or bad it depends
you get used to the flow over time but
coming in you might be a little
overwhelmed like wait we were supposed
to deliver
this for this upcoming iteration but nah
it's like taken out entirely don't think
about it until next duration
uh yes victor
yeah could i can i have just a warning
yeah because
uh i i do agree uh you know with our
colleagues here um when you compare the
work of a startup to the work uh inside
a corporation
the working a corporation seems kind of
mundane you know
it can't be you know uh boring even
uh it is exciting to work with startups
and as you know as they were saying you
know different hats uh adapting to
change
my only warning is that oftentimes
you know all this you know innovation
and exciting
uh i would say behavior
within startups can be easily just be
innovation theater
and you know you give your
appearance that everything is you know
working towards the goal etc but you're
just you know not necessarily
progressing towards actual change and so
that's my only warning you know
sometimes uh founders will come your way
and they will promise heaven you know to
you and you can actually decide to
follow their footsteps uh but you will
go down instead of up you know so be
careful i'm not buying into just
innovation theater and make sure that
you're really buying into a vision that
has a lot of execution uh involved uh
it's my only i'm my only warning i think
innovation can be found in multiple
spaces within corporations as well uh as
with with startups
so to jump on that what are they what
are the key signs that uh somebody who's
looking to to join like looking for a
job in a startup should should look into
not like i feel that you you you're
warning us about not drinking the
kool-aid of the founder that has all the
solution and then being like oh we're
gonna we're gonna change the world with
all with our company what are the what
are the key aspects that somebody should
uh should look into um
like when you're doing your research for
the job
go ahead
so yeah this is pretty interesting um
when i looked for qci i asked a lot of
questions about the success of quantum
computing and especially why
the architecture they chose for example
is superior or has a greater chance of
success or even a chance of success
compared to say google ibm or any of the
bigger companies
so not to promote qci too much but
most of the ideas from google and like
ibm were actually taken originally from
yale behind the yale's research so a lot
of that was like one of the movie one of
the reasons that i felt there was
definitely
going to be like there it was it wasn't
going to fall on its face basically
and i researched them into quantum
computing and where it goes and there's
definitely a lot of hype around it but
the main thing is there's also
progression in research as like we get
closer to competing or completing this
quantum computer it's not like um it's
not like stagnant so this is like a good
sign that something can definitely come
out of it as well
yeah i would definitely ask a lot of
questions uh i actually asked the person
who interviewed me a lot of stuff like
so why does superconducting for example
this method for superconducting qubits
why does this speed out like trapped
ions and just like just get a feel of
like how you i mean basically just get a
feel of like the company and how how
it's looking and if they know where
they're going it's definitely a sign
uh midi
oh yeah i i totally agree with these
things i just wanted a few things yeah
so one of them is that
unless it's like a startup that is just
starting and you're like literally one
of the first employees definitely have
in-depth conversation with people who
work there already not just founders so
definitely find someone if you're in
physics definitely find their physicists
engineers and see what they think about
the company and the startup
rather than the founders of course
founders are there
because they really believe in this and
that doesn't necessarily like give you
the information you need
but but
looking at the the people who started
the startup i mean this is these are all
content we're talking about yeah a lot
of people in this field whether it's a
startup or even researchers have this
the issue of tunnel vision everyone like
thinks that what they work on is kind of
like not everyone of course some people
think that what they're working on is
going to change the world it's very
important to understand that we are all
part of like a small ingredient of this
big air revolution that we want to
happen and not a single company or a
startup is going to be that big game
changer to to create like
the next generation of technologies
that's going to get widely adopted so
it's very important to work with people
who understand this level of risk they
understand that this is a very very
early stage
i don't want to even call it industry
quantum is not an industry there is no
revenue there is no market there is
nothing we're talking we're working uh
towards something that could have a lot
of potentials but possibly could not
someone like we work with a lot of room
temperature paper technologies at qnx
for example who knows maybe in some five
years someone come up with something
much much better and that's the
technology that gets adopted uh or or
like entirely like different days of
communicating or computing using uh
quantum properties
so it's very important to work with
people who have this understanding that
how risky and early stage these things
are and how open they should be always
to pivot and change
and matches you have your hand raised
you want to add something in that
position so yeah i guess i have a
comment it's it's it's
it's really nice to to
to hear about all of this and uh
i guess it is important to fear a little
bit about the uh uh innovation and and
when you hear someone talking they're
really excited about something they want
to
uh kind of like uh give you the
impression that everything's gonna be
great but uh i think that it but i also
think that you should fear that but also
uh
you need that i i guess startups need
that right and they need they need to
strive to to go beyond you know and
believe that they're gone they will
eventually change the world and maybe uh
not not by themselves many startups can
change the world doing the same thing uh
there's i believe there's space for for
a lot of uh different companies but
uh
i guess i guess it's yeah you should you
should be careful but i guess you should
also feel the
the hype
you know at some point
and uh i have a question actually i
worked in a startup before and i'd like
to know your perspective on how
how important it is
to exchange knowledge when you're
working on our startup because uh in my
when i when i was an intern at a startup
it was it was amazing i would talk to
everyone we would know everything that
was going on in our company and i it i
think it makes you grow
so much because you're already you're
always in touch with people that are
doing
amazing things so what is your
perspective on that
who wants to take that question
okay i can jump in yeah uh
no it's it's everything exchanging
knowledge and like especially having
this understanding of how bigger things
come together is super super important
in both sides it's very important so
uh one of the things we did at the
beginning when we wanted to hire for
example and have the the senior
scientists in the teams we pick senior
scientists based on two things uh
only people who are smarter than us and
also and and better in physics but but
also the ones who worked on different
fields yeah so not that far off but the
ones that had different experiences than
us because we didn't want to have the
same exact experience and background
getting together so everyone can have
more ways to solve the problems and move
things forward but but right now we will
really try to push for this now that
we're a little bit larger with like 10
people who are not all physicists like a
lot of them like either directly came
from undergrad after their physics or or
electrical engineering and positions
like that
we do a lot of these conversations about
like still this style of like general
clubs and like progress report on each
of the separate like six projects that
we have but for everyone because first
of all we really want our team to grow
because everyone who works for us we
want them to eventually get better jobs
in the future if they leave us or
anything that happens with the company
so we want them to for this to be a
place for them to learn more also
but also a lot of times like we're
developing so many things that
eventually need to come together and
work together so it's very important for
us that
if if you have someone for example we
have an ai scientist who focus on one
position right now or one project right
now but it's important for us that she
knows everything else that goes on very
well because it will make it much easier
for her to know that okay she can adopt
the same mechanisms and help in this
side it can how everything can come
together so we do that very often we'll
spend several hours per week making sure
everyone is on the same page
you wanted to add something you can
admit yourself yeah feel free to uh or
just unmute yourself then okay
um yeah
i interpreted the question the other way
if you mean like
um
how much we know about for example what
the hardware
engineers are doing versus the software
there is always like a weekly meeting
where we would sit down and actually
have everyone go over their general
progress and like if there is any
questions or anything this could be
taken to another meeting sometimes the
easiest way is also just talking
directly to your co-workers because the
startups are really small and there's
like i mean you're we're all basically
like go to lunch together for example so
it's easy to ask a question and just
like catch up for anything that doesn't
make sense or if you're interested in
the bigger picture of what this feature
will do there's often a pretty simple
like walk up to your cockley kind of
thing
and that's like a good way to get
basically um and we have weekly meetings
as well with just like the hardware and
software engineers just to like smaller
groups to go over exactly
what is going on and how the how the
changes in hardware might contribute to
changing your software etc
yeah and i'll say that
i think at the end of the day we're
talking about behaviors uh
you know so transparency
uh leads to uh clarity uh and
and with clarity you can actually
collaborate which was something that
maddy uh said uh earlier in the session
i remember right right after uh you know
um our graduation
uh ceremony at yale seven years ago when
i was here you know i was i was going
through sort of some offers that i had
to work and and i actually got an offer
from the silicon valley company where
one
former classmate told me
that there was no such thing
as transparency
you know all of these teams were working
in silos
and you know team a wouldn't know what
team b was doing and that was on purpose
you know and
i just think that there's there's uh
there's a barrier when you
create this sort of culture
uh to collaboration
um and so i you know i i would actually
you know
consider culture as one of these warning
signs that you really need to pay
attention before committing yourself
your talent to a space
where yes it could be nice you know nice
windows and
the scooters and anything you like but
the space doesn't make you know the
i would say uh the culture uh and and
and i think that's one key i would say a
checkbox that you need to mark you know
a good culture for innovation
for your professional career
great
it's interesting you think that in your
fancy new building with windows and
fancy couches
[Laughter]
you know all fancy but empty so uh
equally dead
we have a question in the chat uh from
eddie uh being in the leadership role um
how much technical and scientific work
do you do during the day today uh both
when you studied at uconnect and now
versus the management of people in the
company uh like what what what so they
do they look like and do you do are you
hands-on science are you more management
now and i wish i used to be very
handsome on science at the beginning
which is like usually the reason you you
start a startup because you want to have
your basically your own research group
uh outside the academia quantum startups
are pretty much all like research labs
it's just that
the fundings are different and the
people you pick are
are different and more diverse
technically background especially
so so that was the original dream but as
we grow a lot of responsibilities keeps
coming in some of them are a little bit
annoying for example like we have
several fedora grants from several
different agencies and many different
investors and you constantly have to
raise money constantly you close around
you you happy for one hour the hour
after you're pitching again like one
hour later and and even though like i
did a lot to still stay like hands-on on
the experiments i used to be the ceo for
the first a year and a half of pulling
things up but then i found someone who
was much much better than me and and i
put her as the ceo currently for the
past two years to be more focused on the
science it's very harder for us to do
hands for me to do hands-on stuff
because
uh
i feel there are two things usually that
takes most of my day first of all i need
to be always like make sure all the
projects are going forward and the way
they need to do so uh pretty much i have
to be talking with everyone every day to
make sure they have no problem
everything is going forward if they have
any questions any issues
but also the fact that
i feel like i'm in
this like continuous two years learning
curve because
every day someone comes up with a better
idea like hey let's build a quantum
memory this way hey let's just use this
technology for entanglement sources or
products or something like that and then
i have to go learn quite a lot about
that i think if i didn't know in much
much more depth to see if it makes sense
for us to start budget for it where do
we bring the money how do who do we need
to hire and stuff like this uh so
i haven't done hands-off stuff honestly
in the past six months or so fairly we
do you still do a lot of science but
uh very soon
uh you you pretty much become this pi
who's whose job is to just make sure
everything is moving forward and the gen
the bigger picture is
is
is is happening
all right great and speaking of money uh
there's always this stress when we think
about uh startups that oh we don't know
if you're gonna have the stability of
your jobs here but quantum is currently
in a space where there's a ton of money
getting poured in by uh government
agencies by uh
companies by exxon investors is it
something like can you share a little
bit uh without entering like uh
privileged information in your startups
can you share that the funding like i do
you feel stressed for cash is it
something that's the stress of not
having a job in a year or two years like
the is something alleviated by the fact
that the the u.s government has these
quantum hubs that uh created like a lot
of fundings for all the i know it's hard
you still have to to request grants and
request funding but like what is the the
landscape in the funding of startup in
quantum
i know it's a tough question nobody
wants to answer
all right
goodbye
sorry guys i don't want to talk too much
but but it's something we deal with all
the time yeah so
i don't think for anyone net startup
especially like whether you're working
or founders or anything no one is really
worried about their future jobs because
it's so easy to get hired if you work on
a startups a lot of people both in the
industry and everywhere else they know
like how versatile you get to be if you
work in a startup and how many things
you learn
so that part is good and usually our
worries are not especially as found
there my worries are not what happens
next months or do we have money for this
part or something like that those are
very easy uh the the problem is the the
bigger picture yeah because now you're
responsible for 10 people then then it
turns to 20 people and something like
that and although we have like it's a
startup you always have a lifetime yeah
so like if you have budget for one year
that's like you're very very fortunate
when it gets to the startup world in on
average and like if you're if you're
secure for one year but if you want to
make sure things happens after that year
now is the time to to worry about where
where does that money comes from so
startup is pretty much a cycle of hey do
this precede and then c then series a b
c d
and then there's some things in the
middle like you can bridge and stuff
like this there's like infinite number
of like names because how often you need
to raise money and
it gets much easier over time like for
us like every time we had to raise money
and bring money
uh the first batch was the hardest one
like we had this seed round that was
very modest at the very first time we
wanted to raise money was 800k
it took me
around 8 months to raise the first 100k
and like a month and a half for the
other uh 700 like when you keep bringing
money and you have success everyone
wants to be affiliated with success so
it's it's much easier even with the
federal grants and stuff like this yeah
the first it took us like a year and a
year easily with 100k in in federal
grants and then the next 18 months with
4 million uh things change very fast and
then peop you go under people's radar
yeah but yeah so that's always the
general picture funding the issue
especially with quantum because
uh quantum is awesome all these things
are very promising but
the problem is that in order to attract
private funding
a lot of people had to do a lot of
hyping that is not necessary
in long term sustainable because you
needed to encourage a lot of investors
why they should come
put money in a technology that may not
even have a dollar in revenue in the
next 10 years or so for you
so the problem is that a lot of
companies have this insane amount of
evaluations like with very like
unmatched market size right now and and
it could go in the past that after a few
years investors become much much more
strict about where they invest in their
money how much they're putting and what
conditions and what evaluations they're
willing to put their money in hasn't
happened yet i've been warned about this
quantum winter pretty much since i
started uh the startup route and and
hasn't been here yet but but it is
always a possible reality it happened
with the ai it happened with a lot of
biotech companies fintech all of these
go through these cycles that people lose
hope and they're not willing to put that
much money
thank you
um i have a question for you victor uh
regarding the the resources that
students can gain uh so we have a ton of
people in in the in the chat and coming
here who are students in college and
might consider joining a startup is
there uh activities or is there
a project or experience that they can
get to sort of have a taste on what it's
like to do stuff so we have people from
yale but also from arizona so if you
have resources from sci city but also if
you know of general emotional uh advice
for that that will be very helpful
yes thank you for the question florian
so so yes um
you know before you actually go to the
marketplace and and and see yourself
interviewing for startups
uh you can actually try this world out
with with side city
uh there are multiple ways in which
students can get engaged with sci city
i would highly recommend to take a
leadership
leadership position with sci city what
that means is that uh everything that we
deliver in terms of training in terms of
uh you know working with startups
we do it through student employees and
so you could actually check out you know
at the beginning of each semester
uh around 40 to 45 opportunities for
employment at sci city that will give
you different flavors of what it looks
like to be in these innovation uh
ecosystems you could you could be a
project specialist delivering a
marketing proposal for one hour startups
you could be a portfolio manager
actually
managing not one startup but supporting
maybe three of them in our accelerators
because you know that's one of our main
programs uh you could also support uh
some of the
uh
training sessions that we deliver for uh
the founders uh student founders that
come to sci city in legal matters in
operations uh we also teach students how
to hire people
uh and so
again one way in which you can get uh
get engaged with sci cities just become
one of our leaders uh student leaders uh
working alongside with us now if you
want to be on the other side which is
the receiving side uh sci city has two
levels of uh incubation for ideas the
the the most basic level is called a an
incubator uh that is named launchpad
where you can come and get support and
training on how to
think through some of your own ideas uh
and give them shape
uh but then we have another level of
incubation which is called accelerator
where you get funding you get mentorship
uh you get also more training
and you can actually you know uh feel
what is what it looks like to be out
there talking to investors uh and and
doing your own fundraising uh rounds uh
all of that is kind of uh skill
development we think uh that once you
are out there in the marketplace uh
we'll give you quite a lot of experience
on how to deal with the real things uh
you know out there you you have
certainly better questions to ask your
employers for future employers regarding
the starter that you may be considering
joining so again
come work with us
or just come and ideate with us we have
multiple entry levels you know
the incubator level or the accelerator
level
that would of course provide spaces for
for students uh in you know in the
audience
thank you very much and this is
applicable to all the universities
because uh sai city is a yale entity but
i'm pretty sure that every university in
the us and pretty much in the world have
this kind of innovation hubs uh that i'm
sure you can find uh leadership position
ae or um in your thing
uh we have a question in the chat um how
would you compare working uh on a
startup
to compare to uh working in the
university like toward a phd towards
like a research thesis and i'll add to
that question like do we need a phd to
enter a startup
and so that's a question for for you
guys like what's uh what's the
difference what was the the biggest
sharks and what was the the
the similar uh similar differences
between these two worlds
you wait do you want to uh start this
sure i was looking for the hand raise
actually
so i actually don't have a phd uh i just
have a bachelor's in computer science
because i went
well i i can't speak for the physics
route because i'm not sure about that
but for
software developing a lot of what you do
a lot of what you apply in like any
environment is very similar
the software paradigms software design
all this like work that you usually get
from like a computer science in general
is very applicable to not only
quantum computing but also other fields
in general so in that case i don't have
phd but here i am um as for
working like the startup compared to i
would say
startup is really much i worked at a
research lab before it's pretty similar
in the sense that you are you're really
close to your colleagues you definitely
work alongside of them you know like
what they want to you to deliver and you
go through and talk about your progress
every week so i definitely got a very
similar feel to
working at a research lab compared to
working at a startup
and it's good because
you like being close to people
you know a lot more about them and they
don't feel like they're just someone who
sits across from you
thank you uh maybe did you ever work on
that
sure yeah yeah no no it's definitely not
just for phds honestly my experience is
that oh i said this very bluntly if you
want to join a quantum startup if you
want to know one of the indicators to
know like how much that the people in
charge know what's going on and planning
properly if you see a startup that is
like 30 people plus not the very
earliest stage ones in terms of
employees
if you see more than five six phds
that's probably not the best place to
work yeah it's it's pretty much just a
big research lab i know startups and
companies that have more than 50 phds in
physics i have no idea what you could do
with 50 you can have like a whole
university like it's like crazy number
of phds so like we started with of
course with more phds because at the
very beginning you need more phds but
over time you need less and less so
right now we are like half and half five
and five uh but we are now planning to
expand too closer to 30 people and like
only two of them are gonna be phds from
the next 20
that you're hiring like you get to a
point that engineering software all of
this matters significantly and and and
even in the business side these things
matter a lot so if if you keep hiring
phds especially from like the same
parent lab or where the founders came
from uh it's never gonna change from
like
from like a research institute beyond
anything it's always going to be just
research
i might just yeah since you started
you're working in a university and you
also work at startups do you have any uh
input on that on that question
i think we
have yeah
yeah so
my experience that
it is similar in some way i think that
startups are like research companies
and then yeah uh
the
the feeling that you have uh
of going to the lab every day
it's pretty much
similar to the feeling you have to go to
the to the office every day in the
startup i guess i would say
uh i also
i think that
the main difference is
that
on a startup you are you know your goal
[Music]
roughly and while you're doing research
a lot of things can happen a lot of
things change but i guess that's also
true for for startup work
but uh i think that uh when you are in a
lab
you will often see people changing what
they're studying changing their thesis
directions and all that
but i think it's it's it's really really
similar i would say
thank you and so we have two questions
in the in the chat that i think we can
merge into one because they want to know
what's uh more valuable and then you
hire in a startups and so the question
has two components sort of like
are people looking for more hands-on
scientists for example somebody working
in with physic techniques and ammo or
like what kind of transferable skills uh
a phd or like your your hands-on
research and science do will be valuable
for a startup like what kind of um if
you're hiring people what kind of people
are looking for then i know there's also
different stages of startups and so what
would be the um there was a to do it
yeah go ahead and mute yourself and
okay yeah so i but what do we look at
most yeah so the i mean of course it
really depends on the quantum structure
you're talking about like there are
startups that are like solely software
focused like for the error corrections
quantum algorithms even i know like in
quantum communication sites there is
like alero
computing uh sorry allura quantum in uh
mit sp enough which is like purely on
the software side for quantum
communication obviously these places
really really prefer the
uh obviously prefer like people with a
background in the software's full stack
developers especially uh for us
everything we do is live matter
interaction so amo backgrounds are
better but what we care the most about
is not the backgrounds or how much
hands-on experience people have but more
like how willing people they are to
constantly adopt and constantly do new
things and learn and grow with the team
because
most of those things a lot of the things
we could be doing here you can learn in
like six months we started with one of
my team members he he was just a lab
tech when he started within nine months
he became one of the
product owners for one of the things
we're developing there is a lot of room
to grow it's all the matter of like if
you're the type of person who really
wants to grow in a more accelerated pace
than for example like a six year phd
so you're talking about growth um okay i
have a question for all of you were you
looking for a job in a startup or would
you stumble upon a startup and then got
that job like what were you aiming for
for that kind of career or is it
something that um
fell onto you and you're like oh that's
good opportunity i'm gonna take it
yeah yeah go go just unmute yourself and
then start talking or um so i did come
from two industry jobs beforehand uh i
wasn't looking for in particular a
startup as much as growth in general uh
for
healthcare like being a database
developer there's only so much room you
can grow like on a front end if you're
just doing back-end work for example so
i just wanted something that would give
me more growth towards a software
architecture which is
more of what i want to do maybe that's
definitely different from a lot of
people here but yeah so
i think in terms of how i landed here it
was mostly talking to my recruiter who
was out there looking for people he said
some professors at yale has this company
going and they're doing some quantum
computing work they're looking for
software developers if you're interested
i could get you in touch with them
and i just really enjoy like i came to
qci for the interview i liked the people
they were really nice and we had like
good discussions about quantum computing
in general that i wanted to get more
involved in this field and that's how i
got here today
ready
okay yeah uh i was always a big fan of
the startups yeah uh industry wasn't the
thing for me just happened to be like a
lot of my friends who went to intel and
stuff like this uh they were really not
happy with especially after phd because
their jobs became like very boring for
them very fast and academia wasn't also
super realistic for me the academic path
of becoming a pi because like it's a
very very competitive space and i always
work in places where people around me
were much much better than me and so i
was like even if there's openings these
people deserve it more than me like at
yale or anywhere yeah
but
the and also with academics is a little
bit tricky especially if you're an
experimentalist there are a lot of
universities and positions but not that
many universities that you get
this decent chance of being able to get
grants and stuff like this these things
are still depending on like your success
rate always depends on like which
university you're at stuff like this uh
startup was a good route because
it would give you a lot of this
flexibilities that you immediately get
for free as like a pi pretty much so it
was like a loophole to just jump on and
and suddenly become the pi of your group
like if you any one of you is in new
york you're always welcome to come visit
our place it pretty much looks like a
research lab yeah we have plenty of
optical tables so many experiments we do
everything from tabletop uh experiments
all the way to and and also even like
theories and simulations all the way to
actually building a product that can be
bought and be used like in a more
plug-and-play format uh so we have a lot
of research and it was a lot into it and
it was like a little bit for me less
stressful more fun to be able to put a
team of all different technical
backgrounds together engineers
businesses software developers ai people
towards something that i was just really
very passionate
thank you
uh we have a very loaded question in the
chat and and uh so i'm gonna read the
question now and then talk a little bit
about it uh is it better to train a
quantum physicist in engineering or to
train an engineer in quantum physics for
quantum startups and so it's interesting
because that question is literally the
reason why we're hosting these tunnels
because
there's going to be a shortage in
quantum workforce and so basically the
there's a ton of startups uh getting
created there's a ton of research lab
new uh new labs new herbs new industries
are building in column and that's the
limiting factor is not going to be
funding it's going to be the finding the
people who are qualified to do that and
it's really not fair to ask for uh
somebody who just got their phd in
quantum physics after six to seven years
uh to start a full quantum computer
science uh engineering degree uh in the
same way we cannot ask somebody who just
got their degree in uh in engineering to
go for a full phd and so the reason why
uh we're doing this thing is because
they it's we cannot uh we can already
have these super people that have like
hands-on on engineering and then also on
computer science and know how to build
this thing and know how to code things
so the the idea is to try to to find
spots for them and have the qualified
workforce in different spot the same way
that some people who are will will work
on software we'll talk and work closely
with people working on the hardware but
will have very different skill sets and
so i think the the idea of like
having this uh these these super trained
people is not really doable and
realistic and so the it's most likely
you should pick a phase like a a subject
that you like the most because at the
end of the day you're gonna do that for
like the rest of your life uh more or
less so
it's something that you you need to
figure out something that you want to do
that you enjoy doing and then pick that
branch and then follow that and i think
no matter where uh where one lands if
it's like in theory or physics if it's
in engineering it's in software it's in
chemistry for the application it's in
material science there's going to be a
lot of applications on the roads to to
work in in quantum and so and there's
also a whole branch that media was
talking about that of non-like
physicists you're going to need
you're going to need people
able to run financing uh getting some
money some accounting some people
getting capable of pitching and so
there's a ton of
things even if you're not working in
quantum you can still like on the
quantum topic themselves you can still
join some uh some quantum startups and
so that's that's something that you have
to keep in mind
if i can uh pitch sci city for that we
can teach students precisely those
additional skills we can teach students
to fundraise uh you know to create a
very compelling pitch deck uh to talk uh
legal
contracts uh you know at the end of the
day it's a business and you know if you
have a business you need lawyers and so
how you can how can you talk the same
language uh that you need for for
business uh we can we can also teach you
uh marketing skills uh we can teach you
how to work collaboratively
with with your team and so there are a
lot of
you know soft skills you know
non-technical skills uh that of course
are required for this uh growing uh
space
that uh needs more than just quantum
doctors
uh yes that's true and one thing that
could be very a valuable tool is all
around the world online and on sites uh
there's some
quantum hackathon uh so it's this
competition uh that lasts i think
they're last usually in person over the
over the course of a weekend but the
online version span usually the time of
a week where you can work in a small
team and create uh solve a problem and i
think this is closer to uh like a mini
startup that you can do you you find a
problem and then you want to solve it
and so you bring some of the team member
together to really try to solve that and
so i think that that's something closer
to to start up that you can you can get
to give you a taste of if it's something
that you might enjoy and the kind of the
kind of work uh you want to do so look
look online i know that ibm has a ton of
quantum hackathon using their ibm clouds
uh
we yqi and sci city hosted one uh last
last year with all with the students at
yale and at um
i [ __ ] be um
i forgot the other university sorry
about that
victor if you remember the university
that was hosting with us oh uh berkeley
uh and then uh so that's something that
could be valuable to to you um so we are
getting close to the end time i think to
finish uh i would like to give you all
uh the opportunity to to add your your
end comment and note of like should we
should we all jump into the startup
world quit our day job and then join the
startup or should we just be more mature
about it and if you have any jobs
opening that you want to pitch for your
startups that's the moment to do um if
you're if you have anything like uh
please take that time to to do so
who wants to
start i i just want to touch on
something that we didn't discuss that
that much but like in the continuation
of what victor was saying
if you're thinking about
starting a startup so if you're from
physics engineering background you have
a good idea you had a research you
worked on something and now you want to
start founding your idea please go find
someone like victor from like day zero
and spend the time to learn all those
skills yeah it's totally normal but you
you realize this very soon you hear this
all the time that founders like us
people like me who came from like pure
back technical background make a lot of
mistakes that stays with them for the
rest of their like the life of their
startup
and you always think that that's not me
i have a phd in physics i can handle
this i i can understand business stuff
like this believe me you make so many
mistakes that forever haunts you it's
like so annoying and forever like you
sit in front of the investors and you're
like yep i was very dumb yeah that was
me three years ago i did that i gave
that equity to this person i did like
this i took this money that i was not
supposed to things like that so there's
a lot to learn so like really when you
think about it starting a startup plan
for like literally a year at least six
months of learning what it takes to to
to run a startup raise money and stuff
like this and each university has
someone like victor that is more than
happy to help you grow in this path
thank you you wait what opened
um wait am i i didn't raise my hand but
sure i can start off
i was just gonna say
for startups definitely do your research
and
know about like what you're getting into
it's
not that scary i mean it's more like if
you want to
work in a certain field and you just so
happen that they have your interests
definitely go for it like why not go for
a job that you like doing than just some
random thing like working in corporation
that you just like sit there and get
pigeonholed all day if that's what you
like that is what you like but yeah i
mean definitely work in whatever field
that you feel has a lot of interest to
you and so you will get passionate and
do a very good job and you'll learn a
lot more too because your interest also
kind of links to like more knowledge uh
as for the question i'm like i can't
speak too much for the hardware side
because i don't work in hardware but i
know we aren't looking just for phds
we're looking for people we can also
teach that have like a physics degree or
something like something a mechanical
engineer actually electrical engineer
all kinds of different degrees so these
are also people we can teach in lab as
well um how to do like a certain process
that we're using this stuff is teachable
having a background is definitely good
because then we can start off from there
and yeah just putting it out there we
are hiring both software and hardware
there are various positions on the
website feel free to check it out
software i mean you might see me during
the interview
all we ask of you is like to have
computer science knowledge and have a
very solid software engineering
background we don't ask you to know
quantum physics or anything
perfect and then you can see on the top
right corner of the qca website you have
a carrier tab and i think i've seen in
every startup uh in every startup
website there's a there's a
fine jonas carrier there's like multiple
times it's blinking it's really the time
to get uh to get a job
all right a few words for the end uh
matches you have a do you have a word to
to end the uh like a last final comment
oh yeah good luck on your job search for
sure um definitely look at what you want
to do where you start off in your career
is not where you end it so if you feel
like you want to get into something
definitely do it while you still have
time and i mean honestly you're still
young
unless you're not but most cases i mean
most of the people i'm talking to
definitely you're still young there's
definitely a chance to change your path
and get into it before
yes
that's it
i don't really have anything to choose
victor do you have a final comment
yeah so uh you know it's just building
on what maddie said uh start a world is
full of mistakes
and uh you know learning to deal with
these mistakes or you can call them
failure is it's quite important for
entrepreneurs uh and innovators
at zai city we have a safe space for you
to try
learn and try again
i think it's it's one of the things that
we are very proud uh here at sci city
because we know that this is a skill
that will stick with our students for
the rest of their lives
perfect i would like to thank you all oh
actually do you have a final word sorry
yeah i guess i do have a final word so
one thing that i a professor of mine
told me this uh
past month is that
uh research is all about failure
and
how you deal with it and i think that's
really close to how an entrepreneur
needs to think about things you you need
to be uh uh
okay with failing and it's fine and i
guess it's really about not giving up
and then pursuing your your dreams i
would say and uh
i know this is for startups but if you'd
like to uh
apply for a phd or or uh pursue a
master's degree uh sukiyan has a lot of
positions a lot of professors working on
a lot of things you can work with uh
quantum algorithms quantum uh
hardware and and all that and if feel
free if you are interested in feel free
to check our website again
perfect i would like to thank you all of
you uh for your time and for your uh
your insights on the startup world i i
it has been a very fascinating
conversation thank you so much for your
time
and uh i hope uh all everybody in the
audience really uh enjoy the
conversation thank you all and we'll see
you in a in on december 10th if you're
interested in learning about job in the
industry
thank you all have a good night and good
luck for your squid game eddie
thank you guys